un homme pour en représenter plusieurs
que reconnaître les femmes victimes de
violences
oui mais c'était la faute des coûts et
du silence cette pièce s'engage dans la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes
l'occasion d'en voir toutes ses formes
et tous ses aspects à travers la pièce
on va aborder à la fois les violences
conjugales mais également aussi les
violences dans le monde professionnel et
la sphère également la sphère publique
puisque on va parler aussi des
transports en commun donc on a dans la
pièce un panel assez large de la société
et des situations de violence vécue par
les femmes 80% des femmes en situation
de handicap ont été victimes de
violences une situation dénoncée à
travers cette pièce certains individus
et y en avait 1 ce matin se croient
autorisés à avoir à mon égard des gestes
discrètement déplacer assurer qu'ils
sont que malté cité ne m'aime permettra
pas de les identifier quatre victimes
sur cinq ne porte pas plainte la pièce
rappelle l'importance du rôle des
associations
j'ai vécu exactement la même chose que
vous votre vie tourne autour de de la
violence et de l'humeur de votre tyran
n'être plus qu'une chose qui tremble
l'arbre âme aux témoignages des
violences physiques mais aussi
psychologiques reprises dans la pièce un
constat prenant pour les comédiens ça
interroge les mécanismes même au
quotidien qu'on peut rencontrer aussi en
soi de ce qui rabaisse tout ce qui
diminue ce qui fait de soi un objet donc
il ya beaucoup de choses qui résonne mon
texte
après la pièce des coûts et du silence
du théâtre interactif les spectatrices
ont pu se mettre en scène avec les
comédiens concernant les thèmes évoqués
durant le débat une façon de déclencher
la prise de parole c'est pour
avoir une plus grande conscience de ce
qui se passe le mari il est parfois
considéré comme quelqu'un de très bien
quoi un type bien qui s'occupe de ses
enfants parce qu'ils lui fassent aussi
ce message via d'autres personnes donc
c'est trop facile
donc les gens et prennent conscience
mais il faut donner un peu de la place
aux pièces comme ça justement le service
de prévention et sécurité de la ville de
trappes a rappelé les permanences de
psychologues
un recueil avec les différentes
structures dead a été remis au public